thanks nate if you're looking for some
at-home entertainment this weekend
i've got you covered let me introduce
you to the movie the devil has a name
a story inspired by real life events
about a small town farmer
taking on a big time oil company that
has been polluting his land
take a look see if this farmer is
successful with this loss
then he has established a precedent it's
going to be open season for all the big
boys
the net present value rule states if you
make more money doing it
than what it would cost if you get
caught doing it continue doing it
the film it has an all-star cast
including edward
james almost i spoke with edward about
the movie
and his iconic roles and features like
stand and deliver
selena and of course the always serious
lieutenant castillo
in miami vice
president
don't ever come up to my face like this
again
edward james almost thank you so much
for joining us how are you
very good jc very very good thank you
for asking
i got to tell you this this is kind of a
trip because um i love seeing you smile
and here's why because as a young
boy i was into miami vice but and i
couldn't wrap my
i was so young i couldn't wrap my head
around the show i was more into the cars
and the music and your your character
you never smiled
so you know as a little kid i was
intimidated by you and then as i got
older every time i see you smile
it makes me smile well jc
uh thank you i'm a pretty happy person
uh
lieutenant martin castillo had nothing
to be happy about that's why he never
smiled
well the movie the devil has a name i
watched it i loved it
uh we've got a small town farmer taking
on a big-time oil company who has been
polluting his water for over 10 years
what inspired you to get involved
in this project as an actor and also as
a director the story
period and foremost uh and that's why
everybody joined me that's why david
strathearn alfred molina
uh marty sheen karen bosworth
uh kate bosworth excuse me kate bosworth
and
haley joel osmond and all of these
tremendous
actors got involved with helping me and
i will say that
of the films that i made this is really
one of the strongest ones i've
been able to participate in because the
story i read somewhere that stand and
deliver
is the most viewed movie of all time
one is is that true and then why do you
think that movie still resonates today
well it's been said that and
the reason is because the fact that over
the last 33 years
uh tens of thousands of teachers across
america
use it yearly to motivate and inspire
themselves and their students and
and that's been going on for 33 years
and they don't use any film like that
any of the films that have been made are
used
that way as an educational tool you've
done so many different uh
amazing roles throughout your career i
want to hit you real fast with some
roles you played
in the beginning of your career okay i
want you to identify
the show that you're on so for example
the character julio
gutierrez do you know what show that's
from i played uh
ponch's cousin was that the is that the
am i right you're so close so uh julio
gutierrez was starsky and hutch
oh oh my god wrong that was slightly was
first
actually before uh the
one with uh with chips
yes we play your character's name was
henry in chips
henry and julio okay thanks well this
was such an honor thank you so much
edward james almost a it's a great movie
the devil has a name
the devil has a name is available on
demand today
in las vegas now we'll be right back